welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of marvel
studios what if episode 5 what if
zombies which allows us to laugh through
a zombie apocalypse until we remember
that earlier apocalypse we were worried
about i'm gonna break down all the
easter eggs and animation details that
you might have missed from this episode
here we go we open with hulk blasting
back to earth via the bifrost in
avengers infinity war the framing
actually matches those shots including
the tilt rotation on the shot of
manhattan and the reflection of hulk in
the sanctum window but this time the
bifrost blast to the staircase comes not
as strange and wong are there but
leaving banner all alone
uh
hello
no one except for the cloak of
levitation who might be earth's sole
survivor by the end of all this but no
word on what happened to wanda maximoff
and hulk holku's skin is supposed to be
impenetrable or to bucky or how thor
would have held up or a groot who as a
fluorocolossus is made of bark like
cellulose instead of skin tissue and
blood i'm just saying we need a marvel
zombies part 2 and get this groot a cape
the cloak hooks up banner with the
maroon robes that sorcerers typically
wear and he asks was i too late
he's assuming that thanos already
succeeded in snapping away life i guess
he wouldn't know how long he was out for
ebony ma and call obsidian beam down to
the street without the heavy gusts of
their q-ship hulk refuses to come out as
he does during this scene infinity war
actually in that movie ebony mob
proclaims hear me
and rejoice you are about to die at the
hands of the children of thanos here it
plays out this way hear me and rejoice
come on come on
what do you mean no
you are about to die at the hands of the
children of yeah mixing in banners later
moment from infinity war come out come
out come out
what do you mean no and right as ebony
moss says hands iron man's hand appears
and ma is cut off right before he says
thanos avoiding reminding us of the guy
to set up the final twist of the episode
banner's three co-warriors from infinity
war arrive
tony with alan silvestri's avengers
music there the silhouettes of wong and
iron man and doctor strange look haggard
and tattered tony is wearing his mark 50
nanotech armor from infinity war but
notice how his helmet is retracted the
better to bite us with banner says oh
boy are you guys screwed which banner
says later infinity war when thor
arrives late
you guys are so screwed now through the
dust cloud you can make out a super
tattered zombie strange jumping through
a portal directly at ebony ma no care
whatsoever if ma were to take the time
stone in the eye of agamotto they mask
this brawl with thicker dust in a lens
flare and they use sound effects in
obsidian's hand to hint at the violence
oh that sort of seems like overkill
notice how the zombies can still use
their weaponry in their sorcery in
robert kirkman's marvel zombies comics
the virus known as the hunger leaves the
infected's full mental capacity
unaffected it just really leaves them
with a carnivorous drive akin to zombies
the comics also follow the fantastic
four magneto galactus a whole bunch of
characters as the virus spreads to
alternate realities and we learned that
the outbreak began when a watcher from
the earth z dimension sent a zombified
sentry to earth 2149 so yes a watcher
was behind all of this in this case our
watcher doesn't intervene and it's
caused by something else that i'll get
to later notice how zombie stark's face
is decayed but his earlobe still has a
bit of flesh tone in there kind of like
how we see with zombie cap's ear later
showing how this virus is really just
affecting their limbic systems in their
brains and how with the right mind stone
frequency this could be reversed but to
a pretty decayed bony body and what kind
of quality of life are we talking there
long gnaws on obsidian severed arm
similar to how he uses a portal to sever
that arm infinity war but then wong here
dies a similar way portal severance this
time to the head banner kicks it just
like how he kicked obsidian's arm all
freaked out wasp uses a swarm of flying
ants to disintegrate these zombies who
are you
all that's left you have some fun
wordplay from hope there hope is all
that's left the dad jokes aren't limited
to scott here spider-man scoops up
banner
relax i'm just your friendly
neighborhood spider-man oh yeah well
then what the hell happened to the
neighborhood yeah peter parker's voice
not by tom holland but by actor and
singer hudson teams notice how his suit
isn't exactly like the one we saw in
infinity war perhaps because sony might
own that exact movie version of the suit
so instead they used the disney owned
version of the suit that they made for
the disney parks the watcher says like
too many great catastrophes this one
sprang from a place of love
and hope yeah notice how he's much
closer to us than he usually is and now
we see his mouth as he's talking like
ever since nearly interfering last
episode he is getting nearer and nearer
each week as he takes a less godly and
more personified form he explains how
two weeks earlier hank pym went to
rescue janet van dyne from the quantum
realm notice how pym approaches a
crystalline barrier which in ant-man the
wasp represented the barrier between
subatomic space and the separate
dimension that the quantum realm is but
here the distant orange light the
tendrils the floating crags are all on
this side of the barrier and he lands on
a different surface than before and
there is a problem janet van dyne
contracted a quantum virus that
corrupted her brain
yeah so the watcher doesn't go into any
further detail about the origins of this
quantum virus or why janet hank didn't
get affected when in the quantum realm
in the movie which is a bit weird
because every episode up until now we
see at least some kind of deliberate
turning point from the movies that
characters make whether it's peggy
carter deciding to stay in the room or
doctor strange still being in a
relationship with christine palmer so
what is the difference here well after
staring at this for too long notice
these purple pillars of light that now
beam up from below those were not in the
movie i'm wondering if these could be
the origins of the virus and inside
marvel i speculated that janet could
have been intentionally infected by
someone who engineered this virus
specifically to get to thanos maybe even
engineered by the celestials known to be
experimental biological engineers of the
marvel universe hoping perhaps that
zombie thanos might use his stones
instead to incarnate a sudden influx of
life because what do zombies want more
than anything an unlimited amount of
uninfected flesh to chew on and that
this might trigger that emergence that
in the eternal's trailer they said
hulk's snap energy surge triggered
meanwhile there's no sighting of the
mysterious quantum realm city that was
hit in the background in ant-man of the
wasp which i now believe to be kang's
kingdom of chronopolis since kang is
returning ant-man of washonomania
there's also an argument that kang could
have released this virus as a way to try
to biologically subvert the absolute
point of thanos's snap on the timeline
i'm just saying the fact that the virus
didn't affect these characters in
ant-man the wasp means that something
changed someone wanted this virus to get
into our reality meanwhile you gotta
love the watcher sass here
that happened
and wasp's shadow crosses over hank's
lifeless hand leading hope to greet what
she thinks is her mom and i love scott
piping in the background there mom hi
miss van dyke hank attacks scott and
scott's hand grasp the glass in the
classic horror frame or like rose's sex
grasp and titanic
but thanks to policy genius for
sponsoring this video if you have family
members who depend on you you need life
insurance like if i was gone tomorrow
not only would the world be without its
pre-minute expert on zooming and
enhancing random pictures hanging on the
walls of mcu scenes but my dependence
would also be without my financial
support but if life insurance is so
essential why is buying it so
complicated well policy genius asked
themselves that question and they
started a company that reinvented the
process from start to finish you could
save 50 or more on life insurance by
comparing quotes with policy genius that
means more cash to put toward the things
you care about like replica paintings
from the walls of mcu scenes policy
genius is an insurance marketplace not
an insurance company so they get you
personalized quotes from top companies
in minutes with policy genius you can
easily apply online and compare your
quotes all in one place and policy
genius doesn't add on any extra fees you
could save 1300 or more per year on life
insurance by going to policy genus to
compare policies head to
policygenius.com
new rockstars to get started right now
that's policygenius.com
new rockstars the avengers quinjet lands
on golden gate bridge with hawkeye
infinity war era blonde natasha cat back
in a civil war suit with his shield that
has already been resurfaced after
t'challa scratched it in civil war and
his 2018 beard shaved supposedly this
crisis must have ended the feud between
him and tony and then of course iron man
and black panther i love this lineup i
would love to see these guys in action
but notice as the camera pulls away we
see the zombies tackle iron man and
hawkeye and natasha but none actually
tackle t'challa in fact the last we see
of him through that crowd he is swatting
back one of those zombies and in that
tight vibranium weave it makes sense
that he would be able to repel the bites
onto peter parker's diy zombie survival
video recalling the quit cut video
diaries that he kept in spider-man
homecoming it's also similar to the
rules in the movie zombieland we see
peter here with other survivors
including happy hogan shirt reading i'm
not single i'm saving myself for thor
skills driving coffee and boxing
recalling his past in the comics as an
amateur wrestler and his boxing natasha
and iron man 2. he wears tony stark's
wristwatch based palm repulsor from
civil war this would be one of the
previous versions stark would have after
he upgraded to the mark 50. then kurt
david desmalcheon's character from the
ant-man films he's wearing his x-con
security jacket skills languages slavic
folklore and crime slavic folklore
referring to his baba yaga ghost story
that comes back later this episode bucky
barnes showers in a usa themed shower
curtain as he later in this episode
bears the stars and stripes of the
shield he's listed as silent but deadly
skills murder killer arm heavy sleeper
of course referring to his deep freeze
hibernation bucky has the new black
vibranium arm that was given to him in
infinity war so the wakandans must have
given him this arm as this zombie
outbreak began he says you know all i
have to do is squeeze right okay kind of
like indiana jones threat to that nazi
woman in the last crusade
all i have to do is squeeze
then sharon carter listen it's the
blonde bond skills spycraft first aid
eulogies referring to how she patched up
team cap and eulogized peggy carter in
civil war and final member of the team
okoye who's in the u.s looking for
t'challa after he went missing we see
how their base is a series of subway
cars and a bus and then a school bus all
whipped together suspended between
buildings a pretty genius idea for a
sanctuary in a zombie apocalypse i'm not
sure how they were able to avoid falcon
all this time they use what looks like
stark's gauntlet from the hulkbuster
armor to hollow project the signal that
they've received it also looks like they
got a super nintendo over on the right
banner says well it looks to me like
your message is in non-linear hexa code
that location look familiar agent carter
it's camp lehigh in new jersey camp
lehigh of course where cat first trained
in the first movie and where he and tony
stole the tesseract an endgame in 1970
and where cap and natasha discovered
zola's algorithm in winter soldier
leading that place getting bombed back
in 2014 though most of it appears intact
this episode happy drives them to grand
central i thought you were an uber
driver no no i'm a personal chauffeur
there's a difference
yeah we realized that they are in the
pymtech van that hope drove in ant-man
and the wasp with this jump scare
evoking that huge pigeon and they use it
to burst through the zombie's head now
grand central station is where hulk
punched thor out of the movie and the
prologue of spider-man homecoming but
this station does not connect to new
jersey anyway they split up uh splitting
up do you guys just not have horror
movies in wakanda we don't need them we
have american reality shows yeah peter
brings up a crucial point in most zombie
fiction that a lot of the times
characters are not as aware of horror
movie tropes as the audiences a meta
concept explored really well in movies
like scream and cabin in the woods
starring thor but in this case peter
parker is aware of zombie movies
everyone else is not and in wanna vision
they did scream george a romero's night
of living dead so characters in this
universe should be aware of some of
these tropes happy uses his palm
repulsor
but he and sharon get attacked by zombie
hawkeye and after happy dies his zombie
self still says blam
meanwhile zombie falcon attacks bucky
nikoi and nikoi splits them in half the
kind of kill deny gurira's other zombie
killing character michonne would deliver
in the walking dead that was your friend
sorry about that i should be sad but i'm
not yeah this is before bucky and sam
worked together in the balkan the winter
soldier when they still had more of a
love-hate relationship coming out of
civil war can you move your cena no you
couldn't have done that earlier i hate
you they're able to escape the train
station and spider-man gets the help
from the cloak of levitation it's a good
look on you really you think i could
pull it off maybe i'll grow into it
maybe a hint toward peter's coming
experience with sorcery and spider-man
no way home meanwhile zombie cap kills
sharon notice as she's at his feet her
finger twitches a little back to life
zombie cap's sleeve is torn you can see
he still has a defined deltoid my boy's
still jacked or it's like a bloody gash
either way he's cut notice how bucky
punches zombie cap in that jaw causing
it to plunge down a foot gross cap
tosses his shield at bucky who hurls it
back similar to bucky's shield catch in
winter soldier and it cuts them in half
sorry pal
i guess this is the end of the line
yeah end of the line was their repeated
line to each other i'm with you to the
end of the line pal give them with you
to the end of the line also you'll
notice the music there was actually a
dark minor chord version of captain
america's theme
[Music]
sorry pal i guess this is the end of the
line
hope asks peter how he stays so upbeat
my mom dad uncle ben mr stark now happy
i've lost a lot but my aunt may says he
used to say that if we don't keep
smiling when they can't then we might as
well just be gone too yes this is our
first official mention of uncle ben in
the mcu after his initials appeared on
peter's luggage and far from home which
did stand for ben franklin parker not
big parker hope carries them over the
zombie horde by growing big though with
that tear in her suit and how she's able
to stay large even after her helmet
visor is cracked this would be the first
time the mcu has shown pymtech powered
characters of different sizes outside of
the closed system of their suits
something that the comics don't really
worry about and i guess this episode
doesn't really either vision explains
how he was able to repel the zombies the
mind stone it emits a sub-frequency that
is not to their liking could that mean
the infection is some kind of
encephalopathy yeah encephalopathy it
means damage to the brain meanwhile this
bunker looks like the one cap and
natasha found zola's a-i-n in the winter
soldier but must be a different one than
the one that imploded now remember the
mind stone carried a kind of divine
intelligence that spoke to vision to
warn him about thanos coming in infinity
war and this could have been linked to
the plan i've suggested that this virus
could have been engineered to get to
thanos via specifically the mind stone a
stone that i believe the celestials
first gave the thanos before loki's
invasion since we know the celestials
did used to wield infinity stones and
all this is about getting that stone
back to zombie thanos in this case
because why else would thanos go to
wakanda looking for the mine stone if
the mine stone wasn't there yet unless
it's uh some kind of a oversight
saves scott lang's head in the glass jar
if you drama style nikoi tells him
don't cry you'll fog up your jaw sorry
yeah tula tula is a traditional zulu
lullaby in order to stop babies from
crying they realize vision lured them
there to feed them to zombie wanda
maximoff t'challa has lost a leg similar
to how he does in the marvel zombies
comics and vision says while your anger
is predictable i can assure you my
actions though unsavory were
nevertheless born of logic i still
cannot entirely fathom what i have done
but i cannot bring myself to leave her
sounds like vision found it logical to
contain wanda rather than unleash her on
the world though it also sounds like
loving wanda is just something in his
code which i think is pretty beautiful
but also really messed up how he like
chopped up people wanda awakens her
terrifying baba yaga form at the far end
of the hallway now it's super creepy how
the shadows of her are cast both in
front of her on the floor and on the
wall behind the front one making sense
for the red light source behind her but
also suggests that some light is
catching an additional dark spirit that
must be standing behind her
the cloak of levitation saves scott
making a pretty fun duo between the two
of them
yes of course the levitation spell from
harry potter and i don't think that or
any of these constitute dad jokes dad
jokes are really just solid word play
that gen z keeps moving the goal post on
because they're mad at everyone older
than them for ruining the planet which
fair okoye gets taken hiking
forever
and vision implodes the bunker saying
there's a quad jet in the hangar yeah
quadjets are the predecessors to
quinjets a quadjet is actually what
carolyn fury piloted in captain marvel
and vision to atone rips out the mind
stone from his own head creating the
kind of shock wave that happened when
his mindset was destroyed in infinity
war but also the moment he does his eyes
roll over and he turns gray just like he
did in infinity war and showed back up
as in one division
banner wants to stay behind and let them
escape i don't think i can lose another
friend today so avenge us yes scott and
t'challa are like
dude we're not friends enough and if you
think about it peter wasn't called an
avenger until tony stark knighted him in
infinity war which never happened here
so banner telling him to avenge them
gives peter that promotion banner
finally forces hulk out of hiding and he
and wanda duke it out but we never see
what comes from that or where bucky
landed giant hope tries to grab the jet
and fails and pissed chucks a zombie at
them
t'challa tells peter in my culture
that is not the end they are still with
us as long as we do not forget them a
touching callback to chadwick boseman's
memorable words after t'chaka's death
and civil war in my culture death it's
not the end it's marve stepping off
point yet as they arrive to wakanda
inside the shield gates zombies claw to
get out standing above zombie dora
milaje and jabari warriors zombie thanos
stands victorious five out of six stones
in his gauntlet notice how his pose
matches his final do it myself shot in
the age of ultron post-credits scene now
to think about where thanos has been in
this timeline he must have gotten the
reality stone from nowhere in the soul
stone from vermeer meaning gamora is
dead and he had planned to rendezvous
with ebony maw on titan for the time
stone but now that ma never made that
trip thanos probably went directly to
earth to recover the eye of agamotto
from new york and i guess then headed to
the only place the surviving avengers
would go or maybe they just didn't think
about this i don't know the point is
thor is still out there somewhere along
with fruit and rocket and the guardians
of the galaxy minus gamora meaning there
is more what if to what if zombies to
explore as zombie thanos would probably
go planet to planet now and then maybe
even to other timelines by infecting the
tva so marvel again please give us a
marvel zombies part two keep us smiling
for hope you can support new rockstars
by checking out our merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com follow me on
instagram and twitter at eavos follow
and subscribe to new rockstars thanks
for watching bye
[Music]
you